today we're going to talk about the best
remedy for chronic fatigue syndrome as
well as fibromyalgia now these two
symptoms usually come together
and if you try to
address or treat these two conditions
with the wrong treatment
it's going to take a long time to fix it
and so if you don't understand
the mechanism you end up getting on a
remedy or a drug that just makes it
worse however most of the data aligns
with
a virus okay so it's viral in nature
usually the epstein-barr virus which is
in the herpes family and believe it or
not a good percentage of the population
has been infected by epstein-barr virus
but we're not talking about a new
infection we're talking about an old
infection being reactivated
the unique thing about the epstein-barr
virus is it goes into a latent or
dormant stage and it kind of sits there
inactive until you experience stress
so it's the stress
and the alteration in cortisol
that reactivates this virus
one thing you need to know about
cortisol is when you have an increase in
cortisol
because of stress
your immune system becomes paralyzed and
one of the best remedies
for that is olive leaf
extract now what is an olive leaf
extract that can help someone with
chronic fatigue syndrome
well it's a phytonutrient called
oloropine and this phytonutrient is the
chemical that gives olives its bitter
taste in fact
you couldn't consume an olive without
having to remove most of this first or
else it would be
too bitter and so companies ferment
their olives
to remove a lot of this
phytonutrient so you can consume olives
and just as a side note unfortunately
most olives that are fermented which
have all this friendly bacteria are then
pasteurized and so you're sterilizing
and killing all these good bacteria so i
would highly recommend if you're going
to consume olives to try to find an
olive that's fermented and not heated
and it's unpasteurized okay but this
very specific phytonutrient in olive
leaves is a very potent antiviral
especially for the epstein-barr virus
but it also works on the influenza virus
and
the common cold and other herpes viruses
and on top of that it also helps balance
cortisol which is involved in the stress
response that reactivates the
epstein-barr virus but i do want to
mention something about olive leaf
extract when i recommended it in
practice with those people who had
fibromyalgia and chronic fatigue
syndrome
it worked very well on people who did
things to also reduce their stress those
people who couldn't seem to be able to
get out of that stress situation
didn't feel
a big change when they took olive leaf
extract okay so do whatever you can to
get out of this stressful situation and
then the olive leaf extract work much
better now olive leaf extract also works
on a lot of other things
most commonly known to help with blood
pressure it's cardio protective so it
can help your heart it also has a unique
effect on protecting the substantia
which is something in your brain
that if there's a problem with it you
could end up with parkinson's
and lastly this phytonutrient is a
potent
anti-cancer factor especially for breast
cancer and colorectal cancer so anyway
if you wanted a good remedy for chronic
fatigue syndrome and fibromyalgia you
may want to try this now one little side
note on fibromyalgia
if you have it mainly on the right side
suspect your gallbladder okay i did a
video on this and i put it up right here
check it out